en el vídeo pasado espero que hayamos
obtenido la intuición acerca de cómo la
tasa de interés real puede afectar la
inversión planeada vimos que si la tasa
de interés real aumentaba entonces la
inversión planeada la inversión planeada
disminuía si la tasa de interés
disminuía entonces la inversión planeada
se aún planeada aumentaba lo que quiero
hacer en este vídeo es tomar esta
conclusión de por acá que espero que sea
más o menos intuitiva y quiero
aplicársela a nuestra cruz keynesiana
quiero pensar más o menos como la tasa
de interés puede afectar el gasto
planeado total y luego qué efecto
tendría en el modelo de la cruz
keynesiana en términos del punto de
equilibrio del producto interno bruto
entonces nada más como un pequeño
recordatorio déjame dibujar la cruz que
inician a primero nada más una parte en
este eje de por acá tenemos el gasto
el gasto planeado luego en este eje por
acá tenemos el ingreso ingreso y sabemos
de varios vídeos antes que cuando una
economía está en equilibrio entonces el
ingreso el ingreso agregado el ingreso
agregado reales
al gasto agregado real es por el flujo
circular del producto interno bruto
entonces vamos a dibujar voy a poner una
línea en donde están todos los puntos
donde es igual a los gastos entonces es
una línea de 45 grados y si esto de por
acá es un gasto entonces en este punto
de por acá debería tener el mismo valor
que lo que es nuestro ingreso agrega
bueno esto de aquí nada más es una parte
de la cruz keynesiana pero también
tenemos que graficar el gasto planeado
relativo con esto y ver dónde se
intersectan va a ver dónde está el punto
de equilibrio de esta línea aquí lo voy
a escribir ya lo escrito antes como
gasto planeado creo que no lo había
escrito escrito planeado y esto lo
podemos escribir también como se lleve
gastos planeados y estoy acá va a ser
igual va a ser igual a nuestro consumo
agregado y el consumo agregado está en
función del ingreso disponible en yemen
usted que es ingreso disponible ingreso
agregado menos impuestos agregados pero
quiero dejar muy claro que estoy acá no
sé por qué menos t esto es que se está
en función de yemen usted si tú me das
y entonces yo te puedo dar un ace bueno
hasta ahorita en nuestro análisis de la
cruz keynesiana hemos sido muy
tradicionales hemos pensado que la
función de consumo es una función lineal
así nuestra función de consumo se en
función de yemen usted es igual a algo
del estilo como el consumo autónomo más
la propensión marginal al consumo por
por nuestro ingreso agregado menos los
impuestos esto ya casi es multiplicar
aquí podemos distribuir el segundo vale
aquí afuera le está diciendo que ese es
una función de yemen usted bueno
entonces estoy acá nada más es una parte
del gasto planeado pero más allá de eso
tenemos más la inversión planeada e
inversión planeada estamos hablando de
la pura planeación y ve antes teníamos
que la inversión planeada era fija pero
ahora ya la podemos pensar como que está
en función de la tasa de interés real
bueno además de eso también teníamos el
gasto gubernamental y la exportación
neta muy bien para alguna tasa de
interés dada podemos graficar esta línea
de acá ésta es una función de consumo
verdad que simplemente es una línea
tiene cierta pendiente positiva e
interpreta el eje vertical en algún
lugar de por acá verdad tiene una
intersección positiva entonces todo
estoy acá para una tasa interés real va
a ser constante de modo que nuestros
gastos planeados nuestra función se va a
ver más o menos así algo como de ese
estilo entonces esto de acá es que vamos
a ponerle yépez sub uno porque estoy acá
es el primer gp cuando tenemos una
déjame escribirlo así voy a reescribir
lo por acá la función de consumo que
está en función de yemen usted más el
nivel de inversión planeada en vamos a
ponerle aquí la tasa de interés r 1 la
tasa de interés real es de 1 más el
gasto gubernamental más la exportación
neta más nx
y ya vimos como lo hemos visto en otros
análisis de las cruces keynesianas que
este de acá es nuestro nivel de
equilibrio del producto interno bruto es
sobre nuestra línea de gasto planeado el
lugar en donde el ingreso es igual al
gasto o bien donde la producción es
igual al gasto o sea tenemos un balance
y tenemos un equilibrio en la economía o
sea los inventarios no se están gastando
muy rápido tampoco se están acumulando
muy por encima de lo que planeamos al
inicio lo que quiero pensar ahorita es
qué sucede si la tasa de interés si la
tasa de interés real se mueve de r1 r2
entonces qué sucede si la tasa de
interés real se mueve de r1 r2 y en
particular supongamos que r2 o sea ahora
tendremos en la inversión planeada en r2
y vamos a suponer que r2 es menor que r
uno esencialmente nos estamos
preguntando qué sucede si la tasa baja
bueno pues ya lo sabemos verdad si la
tasa de interés baja entonces la
inversión planeada la inversión planeada
aumenta de modo que si todo lo demás es
igual si esta cosa se mueve hacia arriba
si esté sumando d
o sea si si la entrada se va de r1 r2
entonces toda esta expresión va a
aumentar de modo que vamos a tener un
aumento verdad un desplazamiento hacia
arriba de los gastos planeados para
cualquier nivel de ingreso entonces va a
acabar viéndose más o menos así van algo
como de este estilo éste tiene una
cierta diferencia déjame escribirla por
acá entonces esta distancia va a ser el
cambio en el gasto planeado eso aumentó
porque la tasa de interés disminuyó eso
lo vimos en el vídeo pasado y también
vimos en el vídeo pasado que cuando
mueves bueno más bien estamos viendo en
este vídeo que cuando desplazamos eso
hacia arriba también aumenta el producto
interno bruto como se aumenta la
inversión porque baja la tasa interés
llegamos a un nuevo punto de equilibrio
y ese punto de equilibrio es más alto es
un mayor producto interno bruto o bien
ingreso agregado y sabemos de otros
vídeos también que esta distancia de por
acá es lo mismo que nuestro
multiplicador por qué cambio que se
movía acá arriba entonces la cantidad
que se movió fue d
en la inversión planeada y luego hay que
multiplicar eso fuera el multiplicador
donde el multiplicador es uno entre la
propensión marginal al ahorro o bien uno
entre uno menos la propensión marginal
al consumo y la propensión marginal al
consumo como estamos suponiendo que es
constante porque si no no nos hubieran
salido las cuentas sería esta expresión
de acá entonces sería igual a nuestro
ser bueno pero la idea más importante
así la perspectiva general de conforme
vamos avanzando hacia construir el
modelo y ese lm realmente es decir mira
sabes que si la tasa real aumenta la
inversión planeada disminuye si la tasa
disminuye que es lo que vimos en este
ejemplo de por aquí déjame escribirlo va
entonces
2b la inversión planeada 2 es igual hace
en función de yemen usted más nuestra
nueva inversión planeada con esta nueva
tasa r 2 más g más la exportación de
texto de aquí es nuestro nuevo ye 2
planeado verdad entonces en este ejemplo
lo que vimos es que si la tasa de
interés disminuye entonces la inversión
planeada
si la inversión planeada se aumenta y
eso lo que hace en total es que el gasto
planeado aumente y entonces que el
producto interno bruto también aumente
déjame poner otra relación que es
bastante análoga a esto de por acá
porque realmente es un cambio en esta
expresión nada más se multiplica por el
multiplicador y obtenemos algo muy
parecido entonces la gran lección de
esto es que si la tasa de interés real
aumenta no solo la inversión planeada
disminuye eso va a mover toda esta curva
toda esta década hacia abajo y también
va a causar que nuestro equilibrio del
producto interno bruto disminuya y justo
va a disminuir el multiplicador por
cuánto disminuye esta expresión si la
tasa de interés disminuye entonces la
inversión planeada es lo que vimos en el
vídeo pasado aumenta y eso va a causar
que toda esta línea justo como pasó en
este vídeo se desplace hacia arriba si
esta curva se desplaza hacia arriba
entonces el equilibrio del producto
interno bruto va a cambiar lo que cambio
esta expresión por el multiplicador
entonces el producto interno bruto
aumentar entonces realmente es una
relación muy similar verdad en términos
de cómo se mueven las cosas de hecho
podemos graficar lo ya sé a veces los
los economistas son famosos por no
siempre graficar la variable
independiente dónde va pero bueno lo que
vamos a construir hábitos en nuestra
curva y ese qué quiere decir inversión y
ahorro en inglés después vamos a
platicar más de eso pero la convención
es poner la tasa de interés acá en el
eje vertical y poner poner el producto
interno bruto por acá en el eje
horizontal entonces si vemos esta
relación
si hay una tasa interés alta entonces
tenemos un nivel bajo de producto
interno bruto y si tenemos una tasa de
interés baja entonces vamos a tener un
alto nivel del producto interno bruto
verdad porque aumente el gasto si
aumente el gasto se desplace el punto de
equilibrio y el producto interno bruto
aumenta bajo interés alta producción
entonces nuestra curva se vería más o
menos así entonces la curva que
relaciona el producto interno bruto con
la tasa de interés real se vería así y
se conoce como la curva y ese otra vez y
ese viene de investment ratings e
inversión y ahorros en inglés hasta
ahorita sólo hemos visto la parte y por
qué
la gran razón por la cual al menos
basados en este vídeo y el anterior pero
la gran razón por la cual tenemos esta
relación es porque la tasa de interés
real afecta al nivel de inversión cuando
tenemos una tasa de interés alta eso
disminuye la producción vuelve los
gastos planeados hacia abajo y disminuye
el producto interno bruto finalmente si
bajamos la tasa de interés entonces
aumentar la inversión aumentan los
gastos y por lo tanto el producto
interno bruto aumenta en ese cambio
multiplicado por el multiplicador